Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Burcu. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie nicht etwas verstehen, okay?
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich Wolfgang Lipascha.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam beschreiben?
Ja, Wilhelm Otto Ludwig Friedrich Gustav Anton Samuel Nordpol Gustav Wolfgang.
Ja.
Und Ludwig Ida Paula Anton Cesar Heinrich Emil Richard Lipascha.
Okay. Herr Lipascha, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 4 und 60.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
2. Oktober 1961.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 85.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zu sein?
Ich bin 90 Kilogramm, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Lipascha, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe starke Bauchschmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit gestern Abend habe ich diese Schmerzen, Herr Doktor.
Okay. Wo genau diese Schmerzen? Herr Lipascha, also ich meine Oberbauch oder Unterbauch, welche Seite?
Ja, ich habe Oberbauchschmerzen.
Und Rückenseite.
Was hat Ihr gesagt, Herr Doktor?
Also ich im Mittel, Oberbauch oder rechte Seite, linke Seite?
Oder überall im Oberbauch?
Ja, überall im Oberbauch.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Also sind Sie eher dumpf, drückend, stechend?
Die Schmerzen sind krampfartig, Doktor.
Krampfartig, okay. Herr Lipascha, sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Die Schmerzen treten plötzlich aus.
Okay. Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leichte 10 sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht?
Ja, ich denke 8 bis 9.
Okay. Das ist eine starke Schmerzen, Herr Lipascha. Also soll ich Ihnen ein Schmerz?
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut. Soll ich Ihnen ein Schmerzmittel geben oder können Sie diese Schmerzen noch ein bisschen bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Okay. Haben Sie Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Allergie? Ja, ich habe Novalgenallergie.
Okay. Herr Lipascha, jetzt werde ich Ihnen einen Spasmolythika und einen Magenschutz geben, okay?
Okay. Und wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt besser, oder?
Ja, ich fühle mich besser, Doktor. Danke schön.
Okay, sehr gerne. Herr Lipascha, haben Sie diese Schmerzen früher auch gehabt? Ich meine, ähnliche Beschwerden früher?
Nein, Doktor. Es ist das erste Mal.
Okay. Haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Okay. Und waren Sie wegen dieser Schmerzen beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ja. Das ganze Finkel nachdem ich ein Pilzgericht gegessen habe, Doktor.
Haben Sie gestern Abend Pilz gegessen?
Ja, ja. Pilz gegessen, ja, ja.
Okay. Herr Lipascha, haben Sie diese Pilze vom Supermarkt gekauft oder selbst gesammelt?
Nein. Gestern sind ich mit meinen Freunden nach Wald gegangen und die Pilze habe ich selbst gesammelt, ja.
Also nicht im Supermarkt gekauft, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Lipascha, hat jemand auch diese Pilze gegessen? Also gibt es jemand, das ähnliche Beschwerden hatte?
Oder nur Sie?
Ja, nein. Mein Freund hatte eine Probleme, ja.
Okay. Darf ich fragen, wie sind Sie zu uns gekommen? Also mit dem Rettungsdienst oder mit dem Auto oder Ihre Freunde haben Sie hier gebracht?
Ich bin mit meinem Auto gefahren, Doktor.
Selbst, ja?
Ja, selbst, ja.
Okay, alles klar. Herr Lipascha, haben Sie etwas außer Pilze gegessen? Ein Getränk oder andere Nahrungsmittel? Oder nur Pilze?
Nur Pilze, Doktor.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Kopfschmerzen?
Ich habe keine Kopfschmerzen, nein.
Oder leiden Sie unter Sehstörungen oder Hörstörungen?
Okay. Herr Lipascha, diese Fragen sind sehr wichtig bei uns, deswegen stelle ich diese Fragen, okay?
Okay.
Also haben Sie eine Hautfarbeveränderung wie Gelbsucht bemerkt?
Ich habe keine Kopfschmerzen, Doktor.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen oder Brustschmerzen?
Nein.
Das freut mich. Und leiden Sie unter Luftnot oder Husten?
Ich habe keine Husten oder Luftnot, nein, Doktor.
Okay, alles klar. Ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe Übelkeit und ich musste mich mehrmals übergeben, ja.
Und wie sah das Erbrochen aus?
Es war gelblich und ein halbes Essen, ja.
Okay. Haben Sie Blut im Erbrochen bemerkt?
Ich habe kein Blut bemerkt, nein.
Okay. Herr Lipascha, haben Sie die Reste von Pilze oder mindestens ein Foto von Pilze?
Nein. Mein Freund hat mir gesagt, ich kenne alle Pilze und ich habe nicht ein Foto gemacht, nein.
Okay, alles klar. Wie ist Ihr Appetit? Also ich denke nicht gut, ja?
Ja, natürlich. Ich habe seitdem auch keinen Appetit mehr, Doktor.
Okay. Haben Sie in der Lässezeit unwirkulich ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein, immer gleichgewicht.
Okay. Fühlen Sie sich fieberig oder haben Sie Schüterfrost, Nachtschweiß?
Ja, ich fühle mich fieberig. Ich denke, ich habe Fieber, aber ich habe nicht gemessen.
Okay. Und Schüterfrost oder Nachtschweiß haben Sie?
Nein. Aber ich habe Schwindel, Doktor.
Okay. Das ist eine wichtige Information bei uns. Danke schön.
Ja.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Doktor, ich habe seit 40 Jahren eine Niereninsuffisiens. Ja, ich habe manchmal mit Wasserlassen Probleme, ja.
Also was meinen Sie damit? Gehen Sie sehr selten auf Toilette oder?
Ja, sehr selten.
Brennen Sie, Wasserlassen?
Ich habe keine Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen, nein.
Okay. Alles klar. Und haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang? Ich meine Durchfall?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang.
Okay. Schlafen Sie gut?
Nach dem gestern schlafe ich nicht gut jetzt, aber normalerweise habe ich keine Schlafstörungen, nein.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Liebhacker, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie an Nierenversagen leiden seit 40 Jahren.
Ja.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ich nehme keine Medikamente ein, aber ich muss meinen Lebensstil ändern.
Zum Beispiel kann ich nicht alle essen oder trinken, ja.
Okay. Aber keine Medikamente und keine Dialysen, ja?
Ja, keine Medikamente und keine Dialysen.
Okay. Alles klar. Und sonst noch etwas? Irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Seit 20 Jahren habe ich eine chronische Lungenkrankheit.
Meinen Sie COPD? Hab ich gehört?
Ja, richtig. Meine Hausarztin hat mir gesagt, ja.
Okay. Und nehmen Sie ein Medikament dagegen ein?
Haben Sie eine Medikamentliste dabei?
Nein.
Und wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Meine Hausarztin heißt Frau Fischer.
Okay. Ich werde Ihre Hausärztin kontaktieren für diese Details, okay?
Okay. Danke schön.
Sehr gerne. Und sonst noch etwas?
Und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, ich nehme regelmäßig Aspirin 15 mg abends bis zum Frühstück morgens und bei Bedarf Ibuprofen gegen Schmerzen, ja.
Aspirin 500 mg?
Ja, nein, nein, 100 mg.
100 mg abends bis zum Frühstück?
Bis zum Frühstück morgens 5 mg.
5 mg, okay.
Und Sie nehmen Ibuprofen bei Bedarf ein?
Ja, bei Bedarf, ja.
Welche Dosierung kennen Sie?
500 mg.
Und wogegen nehmen Sie Ibuprofen ein? Darf ich fragen? Kopfschmerzen oder?
Ja, manchmal habe ich halbdicht Kopfschmerzen oder Rückenschmerzen, ja.
Ich arbeite als Busfahrer, manchmal habe ich Kopfschmerzen oder Nackenschmerzen, ja.
Okay, alles klar. Das war es, oder? Für die Erkrankungen?
Ja, das war es, ja.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, operiert wurde ich bisher zweimal. Einmal wegen eines Leistungsbruchs links und einmal nach einem Sportunfall wegen einem Kniefraktur rechts, ja.
Und wann waren diese Operationen?
Das Leistungsbruch war sehr lange, ungefähr 20 Jahre alt. Kniefraktur vor 10 Jahren.
Okay. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig bei Bedarf außer genannten Medikamenten noch andere Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme keine anderen Medikamente ein, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Lipaka, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Novalgenallergie haben. Wie umfasst sich diese Allergie?
Es äußert mit Ruckreis und Atemnot.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Allergien?
Ich habe keine anderen Allergien, Doktor.
Okay. Brauchen Sie?
Ja, leider.
Seit wann und wie viel?
Früher habe ich einen Schachtel pro Tag geraucht.
Wie lange?
Einen Schachtel.
20 Jahre.
Okay.
Aber nach dem meiner, ich habe gesagt Herzinfarkt, ich weiß, ich muss nicht Zigarette rauchen, aber ich rauche 5 oder 6 Zigaretten täglich, leider.
Okay. Aber alle wenige Zigaretten sind ein wichtiger Schritt.
Herr Lipaka, gratuliere. Okay. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke zwei oder drei Mal pro Woche ein Glas Wein abends. Ich muss jeden Tag nicht trinken, weil ich arbeite als Busfahrer, Doktor.
Ich verstehe. Okay. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich nehme keine Drogen, nein.
Das freut mich. Leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen? Wie zum Beispiel Todesdurchdruck?
Mein Vater ist vor fünf Jahren an einer alten Schwache gestorben. Meine Mutter ist mit 67 Jahren an einer Niereninfusion gestorben.
Mein Gott. Haben Sie Kontakt?
Ich habe drei Kinder.
Ge-Schwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Okay. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin geschieden.
Geschieden? Sie haben drei Kinder. Sind die Kinder gesund?
Mein Sohn ist gesund. Meine ältere Tochter leidet an Niereninfusion und die Jüngere haben das Down-Syndrom.
Es tut mir leid, zu hören. Okay. Herr Liebkner, das waren meine Fragen. Haben Sie Fragen an mich oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, Doktor. Was habe ich? Ich habe starke Bauchschmerzen, Schwindel. Ich bin schlecht.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut. Herr Liebkner, Sie haben selbst Pilze gesammelt und diese Pilze gegessen. Ich vermute, dass Sie eine Pilzvergiftung haben.
Deswegen werde ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen. Dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen. Okay?
Ich habe viel Angst, Doktor. Ich habe von der Internet- oder Fernseher gehört. Die Pilze sind sehr gefährlich für mich. Oder?
Also ja, das kann sein. Ohne Therapie ist Ihre Situation sehr gefährlich. Aber Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen.
Sie sind jetzt im Krankenhaus in guten Händen bei uns. Wir machen alles für Sie tun. Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Okay, Doktor. Danke schön. Sehr gerne. Bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Wartezimmer. Ich bin gleich wieder da. Ja? Danke schön.
Herr Oberarzt, ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über ihn berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte. Danke schön. Herr Wolfgang Liebkner ist 64 Jahre alt, 1,85 Meter groß und 90 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Liebkner startet sich heute bei uns wegen seit gestern Abend bestehender starke Oberbauch oder epigastrischen Schmerzen vor.
Der Patient zufolge sei in den Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten und mit der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Er berichtete, dass er mit seinen Freunden im Wald selbst Pilze gesammelt habe und er habe diese Pilze gegessen.
Die Schmerzen seien nach dem Pilzessen aufgetreten. Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf eine Schmerzskala mit 8 bis 9 von 10 bewertet.
Die Fragen nach Sefalgie, Sehstörung, Hörstörung, Ichterus, Angina Pectoris, Tachikardi, Dyspnoe, Trussis wurden verneint.
Er berichtete, dass er kein Foto oder keine Reste von Pilze habe.
Außerdem klagte er vertigo und der Patient sei selbst mit seinem Auto zu uns gekommen und er berichtete, dass die Schmerzen krampfartig seien.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die folgenden bekannt. Nausea mit mehrmaliger Emesis.
Er mit dem Erbruch sah gelblich und mit dem Essen Reste aus. Er habe kein Blut bemerkt. Schmerzbedingte Inapetens, Fieber, aber der Patient habe sein Fieber nicht gemessen.
Schmerzbedingte Schlafstörungen. Er sei vorständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft.
Anvorerkrankungen nannte er seit 40 Jahren bestehende Niereninsuffizienz, die mit Lebensstilveränderung behandelt worden sei.
Seit 20 Jahren bestehende COPD, vor 3 Jahren Diagnostisierte Myokardinfarkt, die mit einem Stent behandelt worden sei.
Er nehme Aspirin 100 mg abends, Visoprolol 5 mg morgens und Ibuprofen 500 mg bei Bedarf ein.
Er benutze ein Inhaliert gegen COPD. Der Name von Inhalieren sollte geklärt werden.
Vor 20 Jahren sei er an einer Hernia Ingunalis links operiert worden.
Vor 10 Jahren hat er sich eine Patellefraktur beim Sportunfall zugezogen, rechts operiert worden sei.
Er habe eine Novalgenallergie, die sich durch Prolitis und Dyspne äußert.
Er sei Raucher. Er rauche seit 3 Jahren 5-6 Zigaretten täglich.
Davor habe er eine Schachtel Zigaretten täglich 20 Jahre lang geraucht.
Er trinke 2-3 Mal ein Glas Wein abends. Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater vor 5 Jahren an Altersschwäche verstorben sei.
Er hat 3 Kinder. Der Sohn sei gesund. Die ältere Tochter leide an Niereninsuffizienz und die jüngere Tochter leide an Trisomie 21.
Er sei Busfahrer von Beruf. Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Pilzintoxikation aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter starker Oberbauchschmerzen, krampfartiger Schmerzen.
Bei der Anamnese gab er ein Pilzessen.
Diese Symptome und auch Nausea, Emesis sprechen für eine Pilzintoxikation.
Als die Franzialdiagnosen kommen, Herz-Miochardinfarkt und Pancreatitis in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei den Patienten die Vitaparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Icterus vorhanden ist und ich würde auch eine neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der neurologischen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Störungen der Motorik, Sensorik oder andere Funktionen vorliegen.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CAP, BSG, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Gerümmungsparameter, Elektrolyten, Herz-Enzyme bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich ein EKG schreiben, um Myokarinfarkt auszuschließen.
Und darüber hinaus würde ich eine Röntgen des Abdomens durchführen, um eine Perforation auszuschließen.
Danach würde ich eine Abdominalzoonographie veranlassen, um die möglichen Pathologien, wie z.B. akute Pankreatitis oder Scholesistitis, auszuschließen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Dann würde ich einen Benülsenszugang legen und die Flüssigkeit zuvor, Analgetikum, Antimethykum verabreichen.
Als Akutmaßnahme würde ich Giftnotruf kontaktieren.
Dann würde ich Aktivkohle durchführen, um die Vergiftung zu behandeln.
Oder ich würde eine Magenspülung durchführen.
Der Patient leidet seit gestern Abend diese Beschwerden, aber wir sollen diese Behandlungskontrolle durchführen.
Ich würde ein gastroenterologisches Konsil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Ich würde den Patienten zu intensiv Station einnehmen, um die Mitaparameter kontinuierlich zu überprüfen.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, würde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Ist es möglich, in diesem Fall gastroenteritis zu verursachen?
Der Patient hat kein Problem mit dem Stuhlgang, aber es gibt eine Bauchschmerzen.
Es kann sein, Herr Oberarzt.
Er hat Pilze gegessen. Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Pilzintoxikation.
Aber ich habe schon nicht gefragt, ob Sie diese Pilze gekocht oder roh gegessen haben.
Wenn der Patient diese Pilze roh gegessen hat, kann es auch eine salmonelle Infektion sein.
Ist es möglich, in diesem Fall Ulcosventrikulie zu verursachen?
Der Patient hat diese Beschwerden seit gestern Abend.
Das ist eine akute Anamnese bei den Patienten. Er hatte keine ähnlichen Beschwerden früher.
Bei einer Ulcosventrikulie sehen wir diese Beschwerden früher.
Ich denke, nicht so.
Aber es ist eine Differentialdiagnose.
Wir sollen auch bei diesen Patienten eine Pestofagogastrodendonskopie durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Wie können wir Pancreatitis ausschließen?
Wir sollen zuerst eine Abdominal Sonographie durchführen.
Wir können bei der Ultraschalluntersuchung die Flüssigkeit feststellen.
Und wir können auch eine CT des Abdomens mit Kontrastmittel durchführen, um die akute Pancreatitis zu beurteilen.
Geben wir in diesem Fall Aktivkohlen?
Normalerweise geben wir Aktivkohle für die Patienten, die unter zwei Stunden Beschwerden haben.
Aber es gibt eine Möglichkeit für Amatoxinpilze.
Deswegen sollen wir eine Aktivkohle geben.
Nach 12 Stunden hat es keine Wirkung.
Sie haben gesagt, in diesem Fall würde ich eine Echokardiographie durchführen.
Können Sie uns eine Echokardiographie aufbauen?
Ja, habe ich gesagt, Herr Oberst.
Ich werde Sie über Echokardiographie aufklären.
Echokardiographie ist die Ultraschalluntersuchung des Herzens.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Herzwandstörungen, Herzklappenstörungen und andere Veränderungen genau zu erkennen.
Wir sollen vorher den Kopf mit einem Gel einschmieren, damit der Schallkopf fehlerfrei arbeitet.
Die Ultraschallwellen machen das Herz sichtbar und wir können das Herz auf einem Monitor sehen.
Die Ultraschallwellen sind schmerzfrei und strahlenfrei.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 20-30 Minuten.
Dafür benötigt der Patient keine spezielle Vorbereitung und es gibt keine Komplikationen oder Kontaindikationen.
Nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Einschränkungen und der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
In diesem Fall würden Sie einen RSCP durchführen?
Es gibt akute Pankreatitis bei Differenzia Diagnosen.
Deswegen können wir einen RSCP durchführen, um die möglichen Gallengänge-Patologien oder Pankreas-Gangs-Patologien zu beurteilen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall Flüssigkeitszufuhr?
Ja, das ist sehr wichtig. Der Patient leidet unter Nausea und mehrmaliger Emesis.
Deswegen sollen wir Flüssigkeitszufuhr und Elektrolyten geben, um die Elektrolyten-Balanz zu erhalten.
Okay.
Gibt es eine Antitoxin für die Pizzagie?
Wir sollen zuerst den Notfall-Vergift-Notruf kontaktieren.
Ich denke, es gibt spezielle Antitoxin für diese Intoxikation.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher mit diesen Details in diesem Thema, Herr Oberarzt.
Diese Intoxikation verursacht Leberversagen?
Ja, das ist ein großes Risiko für Leberversagen, Leberinsuffizienz.
Deswegen sollen wir Leberwerte kontrollieren.
Auch wir werden kontrollieren, ob der Patient Ikterus hat.
Ja, es gibt ein Risiko.
Okay, Herr Kollegen, wenn der Patient schwere Leberinfizienz hat, was empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Also wenn die Leberwerte nicht stabiliert sind und wenn die Situation von Leber nicht irreversibel ist, würde ich eine Transplantation bei dem Patienten empfehlen.
Gibt es ein schwerer Punkt? Man braucht eine Lebertransplantation.
Heute sage ich, es ist nicht so einfach.
Herr Kollegen, bitte gehen Sie auf unser Infodesk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifizierung.
Okay, ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg für Ihr Arbeitsweg.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberarzt. Sie sind sehr nett. Danke schön.